I just want to say thank you for
inviting us into your home this means a
lot to us of course what has it been
like for you to be in New York is
settling down here it's been really
crazy I'm someone who's very very
family-oriented so to be away from them
is like the only bad part of it but
otherwise I love it I love having my own
space the energy independence dream I'd
say the last few days I've been reading
your stories over and over on Facebook I
have been watching your videos and what
kind of reflected on me as a mother of
two girls is the fact that you talked
about everything from anorexia but body
dysmorphia how influenced an
impressionable girls really are so thank
you for starting the conversation and
helping girls people don't understand
how much social media will affect a
developing mind yeah you look at those
pictures and you see that you don't look
like that and automatically you're like
great now I need to figure out ways to
make myself look like that waist trainer
is working out not eating it's just it
sucks it does and how has the response
been with your family your friends your
fans how has it been for you and telling
your truth it's been good in terms of
the support I'm getting from everybody
but for me it's difficult because I want
to be this perfect person and I know
that I'm not so just coming out with my
issues is a little challenging you know
I'm very closed off person how's your
parents reacted to all of this well I
think like there's no parent book
there's no guide to what happens when
your kid has this problem and what do we
do about it
so they they're kind of going through it
with me you know they don't they don't
know what's right or what's wrong
they're looking for help everywhere they
can mm-hmm and the only thing they can
really do is make sure that I know that
I'm loved and supported and that they
think I'm beautiful is there a sense of
relief now when you click that button
when you post it on Facebook January
23rd and that first time you spoke out
in media
there is a sense of relief for you now
yes there is because now I feel like I
don't have to hide so much of myself and
I don't have to strive for this
perfection that isn't really attainable
for me anymore you know I'm not a ten
year old girl anymore so who that person
was it's not who I am anymore I've gone
through things I've dealt with things
and they've made me who I am now an 18
year old Jackie's completely different
you know so you bring up the word
perfection what is perfection to you
what does that define for you well
perfection is different for everybody
and it's truly in the eye of the
beholder I guess yeah for me perfection
is just being super tall super thin
perfect symmetrical face perfect skin
I really just want to be able to kind of
have this like out outer moment and
looking at myself and think wow I like
this person and I'm content with this
person but that's not gonna happen
because the grass is always greener on
the other side so what do you see when
you look into a mirror I see a lot of
things that aren't there
I see a lot of weight that isn't there I
see like a crooked nose slanted mouth a
weird face shape you know I see so many
things that they may be there but
they're not as dramatic as I see and
with the weight I mean I could sometimes
look in the mirror and see it
transforming yeah and it's so difficult
because I know that it's not there yeah
but my eyes are tricking me and I is it
getting better
no it's not it's not okay it's getting
better but oh yeah
the dysmorphia part will always be with
me we're XE apart is something that I'm
really just trying to work on mm-hmm but
it's not much better now you mentioned
that your parents notice that you
weren't eating and that there was that
change happening in you did your
siblings recognize any of that change
did they speak up to you or said
anything to you my siblings did not
speak up to me about anything the only
thing that they ever said was come on
Jackie
let yourself enjoy it you're fine when
you're skinny just do it you know when
we're going out to eat or hanging out
with friends and there's snacks
everywhere mm-hmm and it's crazy because
you don't realize how much food
corresponds with fun no you got to get
out with your friends there's food
you're hanging out with them at your at
your house and there's snacks out you
know like it's so hard to have fun and
avoid food at the same time surprisingly
you know the other thing that really got
to me Nye it was actually very emotional
reading about it when I read your
Facebook post about men wanting to hurt
you and you gave an example of that
about a priest dressing up and trying to
trying to get close to you was there
ever a time your parents and you thought
you were in danger and you pulled
yourself away from let they'll not the
limelight um there were plenty of times
when we thought we were in danger but I
never backed away from the limelight
because it's not only my passion but
it's my job you can't just quit your job
for a little bit when things get tough
you know so what we did is we kind of
just got security systems and we're a
lot more paranoid I guess yeah just pay
more attention
do you fear men now not as much as I
used to but I'll definitely see people
and automatically assume that their
intentions aren't pure and I know that's
not the case and I don't put that on
them but in the back of my mind it's
always there you have this gift you sing
so beautifully people say you have a
voice of an angel and you really do and
part of that is you growing through your
career you said you missed out on a
normal childhood what does music and
singing mean to you music and singing to
me is the reason why I exist it's my
purpose in life and if I didn't have
that I would be so lost I wouldn't know
what to do with myself
there's this part of me that's so much
of me that yearns to take everything in
my brain the creativity and just put it
out in the world whether it's drawing
writing singing playing instruments you
know that's that's the stuff that I
thrive off of it's like my energy source
in my motivation and seeing you on stage
at America's Got Talent the champions
you can see how much you love performing
there's an adrenaline rush for you what
was it like for you to go back and be on
that stage it was a dream as I grew up I
was always thinking I wonder what it
would be like to be back on that stage
now that I can remember specific details
better and then the opportunity came and
it was so great I mean you could see in
the footage that when the crowd cheers I
smile and they just make me happy it's
great it's almost a full circle for you
you started at 10 now you're 18 and
you're performing on the same stage I
have to ask if there what you know now
what would you tell yourself at a
younger age I guess I would just tell
her to trust your family and no matter
how difficult things get if you want to
be a singer fight through it just be
strong know there's a light at the end
of the tunnel and it gets better and it
gets better and that's what you're doing
with your new album
the debut yeah the name where's that
come from
so the debut has a lot of different
meanings it's debuting adult Jackie
it's debuting new sides of my voice that
I didn't even know I had until I got in
the studio really yeah
and it also represents me debuting this
classic genre of Broadway songs that
everybody knows to a tee
and putting a twist on their minds in
ways that they wouldn't expect so
they're gonna be different so do you
have an interest in broad ray I do have
an interest in broad way
I would love to maybe like have like a a
two-month run or something really you do
a show on Broadway yeah only if it was
Phantom though oh the only man so what's
with the fascination with ant oh it's my
motivation it's my muse it's what got me
started I don't know what it was maybe
just the romance and the beauty and the
music and how they played off of each
other when I saw it at that young age of
like six or seven mm-hmm but that's what
really triggered my love for music what
inspires you what inspires me is my
future self you know how what is my life
going to be like in 10 years what are
people going to think of my art in 10
years you know I want people to know
that I am an I'm a businesswoman too I'm
not just a singer right I have so many
wants for my future self and businesses
I want to do makeup I want to do perfume
I wanted to close I want to have
charities and take care of people my
goal is to just be a functioning
businesswoman
you